- They're American-made,
I mean, it's not--
- Are they, though?
(intense music)
- I'm a naturalized American.
I moved here when I was like sixteen.
I feel like I missed out a little bit
on the part where you're
supposed to get into Twinkies.
- As a kid, my mom never let
me eat Twinkies. (laughs)
She thinks Twinkies are the devil.
- You hear the word Twinkie
all the time growing up,
but I've never known anyone to eat it.
- What if we really like it?
- Let's do it!
- Alright, bring on the Twinkies.
(wrapper rustling)
- Caught it.
(clapping)
- First of all, this logo is delightful.
- Ooh, it's getting oil on my hand.
- The cream kinda squirted in my mouth
when I bit it, but I'm not mad at that.
It was kind of refreshing.
- This is better than I thought.
- Oh, my God, I could
eat like 5,000 of these.
- If I grew up eating
this, I'd be addicted.
- I want another one.
- What's the push-up count on this?
- I don't know, but it
makes me wanna do a lot.
- Mmm.
- It's really good, though.
- It's good. Yeah.
- I don't think I'll ever eat one again.
- Would I eat more than one of these?
Yes.
Would it give me a stomachache after?
- I just want cheese.
- So we're gonna test the
durability of this Twinkie.
(crashing)
(laughing)
(energetic music)